planking she's got it ah you're
reminding me okay well hopefully I'll be
white magic cubed I'm black again I'm
black like so many games I have to
improve my my coin-flipping skills hippo
says white noise okay I'm gonna play
hippo hippo is short for hippopotamus
hippopotamus
it means River horse in Greek and maybe
some other languages actually I posted a
photo of the hippo to Instagram not too
long ago
there's hippos at the st. Louis Zoo
they're truly enormous and majestic
creatures okay this is this is a true
hippo he finds okay people want to just
check out my Instagram can click the
link in the chat what is white doing
whites just being solid let's play c5
here's a hippo stick with me
so this is an actual hippo but this is
this is a chest hippo whoa free pawn at
66 well I lost my seat while I played c5
to early f6 is terrible because it gets
forts loses more than just a pawn but
okay the Knights are gonna do action
very hungry hippo ooh I can win though
oh no can i maybe I can win the Jeep hog
like takes g5 takes g2 I also take here
first
oh this is nice
White has three legal moves if this and
this if this and this and if this and
this F six would be Connect five but
this is more appetizing and the bishop
is always lurking six is still terrible
it gives white so many pawns to win
let's check ooh
if this and this if this then takes in
win this also this is a triple fork if
this and I pinned so me tactics the
hippo is a dangerous feature I had made
into but hungry hippo tough game magic
cubes yeah don't mess with a hippo
pretty sure hippos kill more people
every year than sharks well maybe this
will go on YouTube for YouTube people
watching in the future don't mess with
the hippo